[Applause]
earlier
today Joe Biden I'm sure he mumbled the
words as usual he said he said this if
Trump wasn't running I'm not sure I'd be
running he said at a campaign event
today how do you how do you react to
that well I think somebody gave him a
talking point they thought that would
sound good you know I just found out
that Democrats are funding Nikki Haley's
campaign I hear that Democrats are
contributing to Ronda sanus or Ronda San
demonius to Ronda San's campaign and
then you hear the talking points that's
the only thing they're good at cheating
on elections and great talking points
they say we want to run against Trump
they want to run well we did really well
in 2016 and we did so much better in
2020 the person they don't want to run
against is us it's us it's not me it's
us because it's a movement the likes of
which this country Sean has never seen
before at the begin we have never seen
the likes of what we've all done
together this is me not me it's
everybody here and millions and millions
I think it's not 75 million people I
think it's 150 million people it might
be more than that I mean who doesn't
want to see strong borders and a strong
military and low taxes and low interest
rates and go out and buy a house I
played on purpose because I see what the
media is doing now I put a montage
together they want to call you a
dictator you use the words I am your
retribution and now before that you said
if you've been wronged and you used
other words as well but I want to be
very very clear on this to be clear do
you in any way have any plans whatsoever
if reelected president to abuse power to
break the law to use the government to
go after people you mean like they're
using right now so in the history of our
country what's happened to us again has
never happened before over nonsense over
nothing made up charges I often say Al
Capone he was one of the greatest of all
time if you like criminals he was a mob
boss the likes of which Scarface they
call him and he got indicted once I got
indicted four
times I wonder what my father and mother
would say looking down hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else